اسم مدينه نيبرو الاوكرانيه ساره مرتبطا
بمشاهد الدمار هذه وبحصيله ثقيله من القتل
والمصابين اثر ضربه صاروخيه روسيه شطرت
مبنا سكنيا الى نصفين بمرور الساعات يكتشف
اعوان الطوارئ مزيدا من الجثث تحت الانقاذ
تقول التقارير ان مصير ما يقرب من 30 شخصا
ما زال مجهولا خاصه عن انخفاض درجات
الحراره وصعوبه الوصول الى شقق مدمره تحت
كميات كبيره من الركام والحديد
ذلك في العديد من العواصم الغربيه
عن جرائم الحرب سيحاسبون عليها
وزيره خارجيه الالمانيه دعت الى التفكير
في وضع اليه جنائيه دوليه جديده تكون
مستنده الى القانون الاوكراني من المهم
بالنسبه لنا ان يكون لدينا مكونا دولي على
سبيل المثال مكان خارج اوكرانيا بدعم مالي
من الشركاء والمدعين العامين والقضاه
الدوليين لدعم نزاهه هذه المحكمه وشرعيتها
سيكون ذلك شكل جديدا
القتال الميداني وفي وقت تدرس فيه قوى
غربيه ارسال مدرعات ودبابات قتاليه